So this is pretty wild in another one of these
sort of Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde moments on
Fox News, Trump daughter in law and campaign
employee.
I think she's an advisor.
Lara Lara Trump.
This is the wife of Eric Trump, not known
as the smart one.
Eric, that is, she ran up against what I guess
now counts as news on Fox News.
And she was instantly reality checked by Fox
News host Martha MacCallum about her continued
claims that it's actually Donald Trump who
won the election.
We all know that Joe Biden won.
There's not anything that Laura or Donald
Trump or Eric Trump are going to be able to
do about it.
Now, the discussion was actually about the
upcoming runoff Senate elections in Georgia.
And recently the question was posed to the
RNC chairwoman, Ronna McDaniel.
Can you trust the Georgia election, given
all of the fraud you claim took place at the
presidential election level in Georgia?
And Martha MacCallum rightly brings up, you
know, there could be Republican voters who
are hearing from Trump and others about how
we can't trust the election results in Georgia.
They may just stay home if they believe their
vote won't be fairly counted.
And Laura Trump actually takes issue, not
with Ranna saying maybe that's true, but with
Martha MacCallum, presuming that Donald Trump
lost the election.
And when she tries to pull this out, Martha
MacCallum brutally confronts Laura Trump with
the reality that states have certified Joe
Biden's wins.
There's nothing else to do.
You can't squeeze any more water out of that
rock.
Take a look at how it goes.
They're saying, why should we even go out?
This has already decided.
Why should we bother?
So that sounds to me like a pretty good cocktail
for having a lot of Republican voters who
support the president stay home and then he's
not going to get what he wants, which is to
have his legacy protected by these senators.
Well, look, I still think that the president
will get four more years in office.
I think it'll be the next four years because
this thing is far from over.
All right.
Just had certification.
Today in Arizona and Georgia, in Wisconsin,
you heard Moraldo moments ago say, you know,
it's time to accept the outcome of this.
What what are you seeing or hearing out there
that that he is not?
Well, those certifications are just procedural
steps.
And the reality is the Electoral College does
not vote in their states until December 14th.
Congress doesn't actually certify anything
until the beginning of January.
So we've got plenty of time.
Sadly, we have become accustomed to having
to work twice as hard, three times as hard
as a normal candidate or normal campaign.
But we're we're prepared for this and we're
prepared for the fight.
So understand that our standards are so low
for what we would expect on FOX News that
this sort of counts as pushback.
I mean, it's laughable, but it's good that
some people on Fox are doing this.
But the bar is so low for what counts as holding
people accountable.
The casual nature with which these people
continue to claim that essentially down is
up, black is white.
Trump won and Biden lost again.
It's been normalized to some degree.
In some circles, it is now normal to say Trump
won an election that he actually lost.
Now, there is something to glean from what
Laura Trump says when she says the Electoral
College doesn't certify until December 14th.
What she's saying is we are going to draw
this out.
This nonsense will be drawn out as long as
possible.
Now, will it end on December 14th?
It's unclear.
This phase might end, but they might come
up with something else to keep going with,
maybe until the Georgia Senate election on
January 5th, maybe even until Joe Biden's
inauguration on January 20th, maybe even beyond.
Who the hell knows?
But back to Fox News just for a moment.
We now live in a world where, compared to
tens of millions of people, Fox News is the
voice of reason.
What I mean is we believe, based on the latest
polls, that 80 percent of Trump voters believe
Trump won.
They believe something that's just not true.
That's about 75 million.
I'm sorry, that's about 60 million people.
80 percent of Trump's 75 million voters believe
Trump won FOX News.
Daytime is the voice of reason on that issue.
Relative to 60 million people.
Fox News daytime is more tethered to reality
than 60 million people on this issue.
That is stunning.
And we'll have more of these example clips
from Fox News on our Instagram page, which
is David Pakman show on Instagram.
If you want to see some of my latest hate
mail, I encourage you to look at this just
for a laugh.
You can follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.